smartphones Amazon social media electric
cars fracking nanotechnology the sharing
economy
none of these pies existed two decades
ago so why are we bitching this is
something we wanted to talk about in
Brautigan you're passionate about this
bill have you been following Alexandre
Cortez a whole lot yes I have been very
very very diligently trying to figure
out what her middle names are quite
anywhere else that's that's about it 365
an hour
can we multiple the hours by is that how
much money have you spent on figuring
this out
so in non surprising news according to
according to her America no longer has
the upper middle-class she said there's
no more middle class in the United
States she's given a couple of
interviews lately but this is actually
something more specific where she refers
to she again she's trying to paint a
mental picture she's taking the mantle
from Bernie Sanders you know you know
he's pissed about she's going further
left than he has yeah okay well let's
see let's see the clip first where she
talks about this this like upper middle
class is probably more moderate but that
upper middle class doesn't exist anymore
in America you know their heyday was in
the 90s when like you know kids had like
fur bees and like parents so you had
like soccer moms like two vans and stuff
like Furby is you bad yeah no it's not
America anymore you don't even recognize
America if you have two actual crazy
eyes yeah you know was most upset about
this is is Bernie Sanders begins more
she's still more attractive than Bernie
Sanders I mean can you imagine being him
staking out that far left position
saying there's no way anybody's gonna
top this and boom and he comes along
territory he started it let's seize the
war of Cortes so when America right now
actually looks like this
how does Andrew something Cortez
actually sees this claim okay we stress
about the 90s in the middle class and
now she talks about two veins and
furbies and like stuff um okay
today actually Americans have it better
than the nine so let's just beautiful
comparison so the average vehicle
specifically what your PC suck we've
moved on steadily risen along with the
median income yes when adjusted for
inflation so even in her examples have
more money and by the way when you look
at things that she didn't bring up which
is what we talk about a lot is for
enterprise advocates and you can comment
I'd love to hear from you with
advancements in technology things like
okay think of plasma screens cell phones
now smartphones again nineties you go
back it was still just a cell phone a
cellular phone you were lucky
yeah smartphone services online
educational assistance we everything is
more accessible than ever missing here
is that what she actually wants to do is
actually make food more expensive think
about that food more expensive when it
all has to be local and organic and has
to go through every thing and single
thing possible that the business
progress is made over the years so the
people can get fed that's actually the
opposite of what she wants especially
try to sticking a paper straw in a
coconut no you're right food is cheaper
right now and more healthy than ever
more healthy options that ever at least
you remember used to talk about this
ease these food deserts yeah food
deserts okay
well now there's Amazon fresh shaima's
on maybe even cheaper if we didn't price
fix so gum yeah but it's like Mission
Michigan because the Great Lakes record
highs and a lot of them and actually
spread through crop years ever the last
few years know this nugget air
Michigan's are very persnickety crop so
they need yeah it's not extreme cold
extreme hot they need a very long
moderate slow thawing winter and they've
had the best year cherries around so
what happened they make them dumped
cherries yeah same thing in Canada from
in Quebec or at least make them dumped
milk because I wanted to the prices that
would be to a little cherries will be
too cheap so we have to sit we have to
save the chain from let's fix the prices
interest and the milk we're not giving
to cheese factories now not given to the
homeless jumping down the drain just
give it to a homeless shelter
homeless shelter fixing prices by the
way we're talking about where the middle
class is getting reamed on prices at
least as far as 2016 and 2017 is
concerned Americans actually spent more
money on taxes and food and clothing
coming up your Labor Statistics myth
socialist a little bit more so if you
want to talk about Americans having more
money again like you said take a closer
look at the government also by the way
cortes something some in cortez sees
Furbies like this I kind of agree with
her there
[Music]
to make another claim that unemployment
is only low because Americans have to
work two jobs let her say it the numbers
that you just talked about is part of
the problem right because we look at
these figures and we say oh unemployment
is low everything is fine right
well unemployment is low because
everyone has two jobs our everyone even
PolitiFact bring this up right again
rated this as pants on fire
so I mean that that is friendly pants on
fire first page of Google and then right
there our theorem yes that first link
says know that that's what's remarkable
about this because I'm pretty sure
PolitiFact is funded by Hillary Clinton
donors pretty much so for Alexandria the
Rays of the jerseys and ol Dirty Bastard
Cortez to get a pants on fire how about
you been working on this I know right
III we want to get this correct I'm
pretty sure politifact is funded by
Podesta's underground pizza sex ring yes
that's absolutely we have we have the
numbers that's currently actually the
number of I think job holders is about
seven million compared to more than one
hundred forty eight million Americans
are employed in a single job this is
important it's not it's not because of
to Jeff and by the way also a lot of
people are working second jobs right now
because of something else that the left
opposes ironically socialists opposed
the sharing economy so people who work
full-time jobs you don't have to work
second jobs they drive uber or the user
home as an Airbnb and submit so it's
really hard to get those numbers even
then it's more damning then she would
hope you to believe again rated pants on
fire but here's another thing that she
goes on to suggest because the other
things aren't necessarily working so she
just keeps digging her hole deeper and
deeper with her bug eyes I don't think
new ideas like universal basic income
the mayor of Stockton he's exploring
doing a pilot program of universal basic
that's also what people get maybe is
right yes exactly
oh my gosh mayor Stockton she like the
mayor of Stockton a city commissioner of
Toledo Ohio
Julie do happen in Flint by the way this
is not a new idea
Universal base think it's been tried in
place like Canada and Finland and
surprised they're not continuing it yeah
it's not going on
and here's the thing this is all based
on the premise and she repeats this a
lot Adnan she repeated as no ad nauseum
just like Bernie Sanders did it's
predicated on the concept that
inequality is a plaguing gigantic evil
social injustice and it's not we need
stronger champions but I don't think
that they see exactly how rising income
inequality has resulted in a very stark
political reality we've talked about
this one you say about inequalities
what's what's wrong with inequality well
don't you think inequality is wrong no
well and the brains eclipse let me
explain you inequality in and of itself
is not a problem if everyone is doing
better people can have greater economic
equality and actually be far worse off
see Venezuela so let me kind of give you
an example let's say there's a $10 pie
okay
the ten dollar pie I own 50 you own 50
right we're equal there you go
you have perfect equality now is that
better than let's say you go and grow
that pie to $500 so now I only have 20%
of that pie right I still have 20 times
what I had before
even the letter R all the gap has
widened significantly you have pie more
importantly you fight this thing this is
why inequality is not cannot be a
measurement in and of itself we say this
it's nuanced it doesn't exist in a
vacuum inequality doesn't exist in a
vacuum
anytime you have somebody who creates
goods or services that benefit the rest
of society that gap is going to widen
kind of like anytime Wayne Gretzky went
to go play for a hockey team guess what
the gap between his scoring and the rest
of the players it was always why than
before Wayne Gretzky arrived in the team
but everybody else played better when
they were sawed off for Wayne Gretzky
being on a team of course not
and this is why cuz I know we had a lot
of Bernie bros who sort of jumped to
Donald Trump and we have a lot of people
who are formerly sort of socialists who
got over the ante SJW bandwagon I'm
gonna hear where you guys are right now
with this cortes business if maybe your
eyes have been open and not quite as
widely as hers but Stanley Kubrick's
eyes wide very wide
are you a pug it's a fundamental
worldview issue where people like Cortez
she always says oh I have a degree and I
have a degree so I know and she'd
understand economics because not only
can that pie grow as we've talked about
but it's always furtively talking but
it's due to human ingenuity in a free
enterprise system we can bake more pies
it's not the 90s anymore I can name you
entire entirely new pies that have been
created since this is a good example you
say you can create new pies I don't know
why I'm sets a really silly argument but
that's the actual arguments that she's
making she thinks a zero-sum game okay
what pies have been created have been
baked since the night as it didn't exist
smart phones Amazon social media
electric cars fracking nanotechnology
the sharing economy
none of these pies existed two decades
ago or came from Venezuela or came from
Venice before any socialist country for
that matter Finland
I'm pretty sure not much know maybe
something during those times I have no
idea I cannot I can't verify that
completely but I'm pretty sure Finland's
crappy so why are we bitching oh that's
right because Cortez sees the United
States like this
hey you like this video subscribe hit
the notification bell or if you want to
continue to enjoy free content support
us at ladder with credit comm /mo Club
where you get the full nightly show an
hour every day free along with all of
our friends content if not you don't
wanna do any of those things you're
probably just here you're watching me
seething you came here to hate watch
that being said the internet was created
for people like you